i think it's waking up
you and the other encyclopedist you've
been
preparing for some
distant crisis
but i think it's here
now
hey guys pete here this is my breakdown
of foundation season 1 episode 3 the
mathematicians ghost i'll be recapping
what happened and then i'll give you my
thoughts about the episode and the
direction of the series of course this
will contain spoilers if you're not
caught up and with that out of the way
let's get into it episode 2 ended on a
big turn with rach killing harry selden
and sending gail into space on an escape
pod a little later in this episode we
get a confirmation from hugo that people
do go into hibernation or cryo sleep and
i assume that's there to let us know
what happened to gail episode 3 opened
with another turn in that it opted not
to provide the resolution or aftermath
of the event on the ship and instead
decided to jump around on the timeline
the episode opens with another voiceover
narration from gail talking about ghosts
the empires and more specifically the
palace of the empire's ghost is cleon
the first we go back in time 400 years
to the end of his reign and see him
planning with demarzel for what comes
after his death this makes her role more
explicit you see that she was there to
plan it that she was involved in setting
up the clone program and the transition
and that kind of implies that she was
actually running the empire for a period
of time since she says that the first
brother dawn they put on the throne was
still a baby there's an emphasis on
loyalty here her loyalty to the empire
to cleon's dynasty and the question of
if the empire will be loyal to her so
far we're only working with vague
references to what's going on with
robots in the tv show which means all of
this is still a mystery from there we
jump to 19 years after the starbridge
bombing it's the strange time in the
cycle where lee pace is playing brother
dawn that doesn't last for long though
because it's brother dusk's last day
before becoming brother darkness or the
end of his life which they refer to as
his ascension this is the version of
dusk who was in favor of mercy for
anacrion and thespis and he's still
thinking about that and what harry
selden said now that he's reaching the
end as a final present they all go up to
destroy what's left of the star bridge
in orbit as they're looking at it for
the last time dawn and day promised to
make something better in cleon's honor
for the outgoing dusk we see that the
work was ongoing when the original cleon
died it then became a very visible
reminder of his legacy on trantor and
then of course it fell during the attack
demarzel has been there from its
beginning to its end and she almost
looks emotional here and dusk asked her
about it later in this odd exchange
where he questions her love for him and
her feelings for the original cleon she
tells him that he's enough but after he
closes his eyes she continues saying
it's just that you always leave me in
the morning he goes to his ascension
brother dawn becomes the new brother day
having grown into their greatness the
new dawn is presented as the old dusk is
ready to incinerate himself and
something about that situation starts to
feel wrong to him there may be something
to this because he's experienced this
same ceremony in the past but before we
find out demarzel grabs his arm starts
to sing to him and then encourages him
on his way to meet his end from there
the story jumps forward another 17 years
where we meet the 14th edition of cleon
who was the baby that was crying at the
ceremony as he's becoming a young man
after that we transition to see the
colonists arrive on terminus because
everything about their landing is
planned out they're surprised to find
the vault when they get there as they
approach it they experience the null
field and everyone gets knocked out they
scuttle the slow ship they crash it on
the surface and then they build up the
colony there's a brief scene of salver
when she's younger her parents are
talking about her being a dreamer or a
thinker and she seems to be fascinated
by the vault we fast forward to where
she's grown and watch her do an
experiment where she discovers that the
null field is expanding it's getting
bigger in her role as the warden we see
that she's working on this fence this
sort of generated field that protects
their colony and we also see the
encyclopedists working to preserve
knowledge to follow through on harry's
plan
solver takes her mother to the vault to
show her that the null field is growing
and they talk about her connection to it
how her mother found her underneath it
as a child at the time her parents kept
this a secret because they didn't want
her to be treated differently we learned
that salva was drawn to it she thought
it was calling to her and then when she
was underneath it she couldn't
understand why it was hurting her mother
when asked if she can hear it now if
it's calling her she just says that she
thinks it's waking up so even though
they kept it a secret it's mentioned
that she's still an outsider and we see
that she doesn't really mix with the
other colonists and to that her mom
reminds her that she's always been
special her boyfriend hugo who's a
traitor arrives he's got a 29 hour stop
on the planet we see some of their
romance some of their life how that
works and after they have sex she has a
feeling which gets her out of bed and
she leaves to check the perimeter she
ends up seeing or more likely imagining
a child running into the old ship she's
never able to catch up with it and to
get a good look but as viewers we can
see that he has what looks like rach's
knife in his hand he disappears after
she follows him inside and she just
finds one of those bishop claw creatures
that are native to the planet there and
when she scares it away she notices
something in the sky above the planet
her and hugo check it out through her
telescope and they realize that
anachrion ships have shown up this is
the first time anyone's come to the
planet in 30 years she takes this
information to the encyclopedists who
don't really think it's a big deal as
far as they're concerned they're a part
of the empire they're protected by the
emperor and all they need to do is just
call them let them know what's happening
and they'll intervene because of course
this is an acrion when they attempt to
make contact they realize that the coms
buoy isn't working they look for
rational reasons that this might be
happening things unrelated to what's
going on with the ships above their
planet but salvor is not convinced she
starts taking stock of the weapons and
preparing for the worst thinking that
they just went by the buoy so they
probably destroyed it on their way and
we see the division here she's
considered an outlier they actually call
her that and basically dismiss anything
that she says they realize they have
about 40 hours until they arrive in an
act of desperation salver's mom pulls
out the prime radiant which she
collected from harry's room after he was
killed just to see if maybe salvor will
connect with it salver had never seen it
doesn't know anything about it and her
mom asked her to take a look at it
because if she was part of the plan it
would make it a lot easier to believe in
it she seems fascinated but there
doesn't seem to be anything that she can
do you see the equations swirl around
and then sort of fall but it's not clear
if she had any effect on that at all and
before they leave she makes the
distinction that different is not the
same as special as they're waiting for
the ships to get there she has another
feeling she ends up chasing the vision
of the young rage again but this time
she finds the creature and notices it's
been shot by an arrow she finds herself
surrounded with what looks like a group
of warriors saying that enacrions are
not allowed on imperial soil what are
you doing here and the episode ends
there to wrap it up we got a pretty
interesting look into the genetic
dynasty and i think that was the
strongest part of the episode we're left
with the impression that after harry's
death after the exile of the
encyclopedists things carry on with the
empire and the clones continue to be a
nice addition i thought the transition
from the end of the second episode into
this one was a little jarring there was
a good build up for that somewhat
shocking conclusion and then it felt
like we were picking up with a
completely different show in the third
episode i think some of the sequences
here work well on their own but the
whole was a little disorienting and
nothing was actually wrapped up by the
end
i said in my last video that i try to
look at the show on its own merits
rather than comparing it to the source
material and i think as an episode of tv
that this one didn't work nearly as well
as the first two the high point
continues to be the production the way
things look the scuttling of the ship
was impressive it was nice to see the
statue of harry on terminus the colony
is believable as far as that goes it
seems pretty clear that they're trying
to have terminus present the polar
opposite of trantor and i think most of
that works on the cleon side of things
it's setting up mysteries about
demazel's loyalty and overall role while
fleshing out the mechanics of how the
genetic dynasty operates it's notable
that the one member who was concerned
with harry selden passed on in this
episode that could be an indication that
they're no longer concerned with the
foundation 19 years after his death and
likely less so in the timeline 17 years
after that is there something going on
with the new brother dawn i mean i'm not
sure why you include that bit there at
the ceremony if there isn't but it kind
of came out of nowhere so it's not clear
where it's headed the idea of demarzel
being in love with cleon that's a bit
hard to parse given that she's a robot
seeing her look emotional is one thing
but i wonder if there's not some angle
where the cleons are interpreting her
devotion as love because they're human
and they see it through that lens as i
said the whole concept of robots in the
tv show is just mysterious and i hope as
they move forward they continue to fill
in the blanks on the terminal side
they're establishing themselves getting
things going and now they're up against
the threat from their angry neighbors
and acrions should still be feeling the
effects of the attacks on their planet
and so i guess maybe that's why they're
there it went back and forth some trying
to develop salvor's character while
showing what the foundationers or the
encyclopedists were up to and i don't
think it really pulled off either thing
but part of that might be related to the
fact that they ended on another
cliffhanger there's some light
references to harry and what happened
salver's mom had the prime radiant rach
was not amongst the people who landed on
terminus and doesn't seem to be around
doesn't seem to have ever been around
but overall the ending of episode 2 is
still a mystery as well
as far as the adaptation goes i like
seeing louis perrine i like that the
divides there between the encyclopedists
and salvor although it has a way
different feeling based on how she's
being introduced i think they could have
done a better job building up the
encyclopedist but hopefully that'll
continue into the next episode some
ripple effects are starting to show up
now from the changes they made the
emphasis on salvo being special
certainly echoes what they were setting
up with gail makes it seem more likely
that there's a reason she's seeing
visions of a young rach running around
with a knife i suppose a lot of what
they're doing now will depend on the
payoffs that follow down the road as a
book reader i miss the old version of
salvor hardin and am hoping to be
pleasantly surprised in what happens to
this changed version and i think i'll
leave it there let me know what you
think in the comments for the
non-readers how did you think this held
up in comparison to the first two
episodes do you think they lost all the
momentum they build up with harry's
death in book readers let me know what's
on your mind just remember to mark your
spoilers please like this video if you
enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon